uh-huh here we go Oh y'all put yeah so
what does he do against the Queen's in
yet I already don't know what it does
this line now okay going to five and see
Quincy to I can take plan I'd be five
huh no it doesn't do that that looks
quite simplifying instead really
dangerous for me and doesn't look very
dangerous but I'm fairly new to the key
to the Queen's Indian so I'm always
slightly skeptical oh my about my
assessments okay so 19 so Bishop takes
Bishop takes special if I guess my takes
so what to do with it Bishop is probably
best i have six so let's reroute it hmm
ok interesting do I go a five year I
don't know I don't really know if that's
a good idea but doesn't feel so bad I
can just double
and we can be six with this stuff
97 looks wrong okay try something else
okay my idea was Bishop f6 but now that
I see the position maybe he really takes
on c5 and I'm not sure about this but I
came difficult to do something else now
now they started the whole operation
all right maybe can't play some g3 him I
can't wait it's not a big deal if you
can play g3 ok I can I here can actually
take with the Queen so okay you know age
60 g 6 these are the questions that and
some I could've chicken on the tree and
stupid player sometimes g3 was a mistake
I could have taken on d 2 because screen
text I was Queen of three so bit
unnecessary
Queen takes I was thinking if five
if I've queen to d6 maybe
hmm maybe gain some space here let's
gain some space
okay kind of a keep it simple method
here hmm Kim yeah I'm only I can just
take them in it's that dangerous look
these six look B 894 some stuff like
that don't really think it should be
that dangerous age for kit could be more
an issue because f6 is not not so ideal
yeah this is a bit of an issue if I play
king is 7 you can take on e6 and play 96
even though
ok 696 knight c6 King d6 no tags at
night is totally trapped a knight is
trapped so is that really I should play
should just play moves this thus I
thought was a bit weird now it's lucas
trapped white resigns yes Lucas trapped
by threatening he five Imperial it's got
the correct resign I've from play if I
have any pins yeah he had to after kini
seven he this was her I was the
interesting move but I man I'm trapping
his night his night is trapped so he had
to go here not be five so when you move
and then yeah the game just continues I
don't know what's going on geforce what
the engine wants to play well eco equal
its engine assessment yeah okay if we go
back we had a fairly solid kind of game
i was thinking actually that night be7
was probably not so good because I
thought he can take and to do this it's
rather corrado awkward I cannot move the
bishop and this is not very very good I
mean yeah why it's better
okay we went before or this seems seems
fairly normal Joe I'm not sure that was
a great idea but it felt like it's
playable gameplay played sp3 h6o no no I
should take yeah this is a this was
stupid because now I cannot take with
the Queen as the night is hanging and
that means he has to take with the rook
and I look 28 and it's all it's totally
equal now and this I couldn't do in the
game which made things a little bit
awkward now I played that routine
movement yeah ok quindi for the Queen d6
was the critical move which she didn't
play and I didn't have a clear reply to
be honest my first idea was to do
something like like this but when here
this is covering well this is definitely
not working so I'm not quite sure what I
would be doing now yeah I can do this
but this is quite embarrassing it was a
bad position it really it was just a bad
position here I'm okay well he has to go
95 you know now is he's losing material
with you five such surprised that he
just resigned I mean okay it's a fairly
simple endgame but I have little time
okay well thanks for watching